they made their way across the channel
just before dawn their message is they
surrounded saint helioport
abundantly clear brexit-related
paperwork and admin
these some 60 french fishing boats say
is preventing them from landing their
catch
so it's not at all what had been agreed
so we're here to try and find a solution
and we really hope this will be set up
the protest was largely peaceful
tensions though
fraying for some
two royal navy warships hms tamar and
hms7
watching on from afar as a precaution
the fishermen say their rights in jersey
waters are being unfairly restricted by
licenses issued by the island tensions
in the dispute
even prompted a threat from france this
week
to cut off the island's electricity
supply every other fisherman around
europe has a license with conditions
that to do with the parameter of the
boat the type of gear it can work
where it can work this situation where
friendship
uh uh worried or objecting to the fact
that there's conditions
on the licenses that they have received
is just ridiculous this issue hasn't
come about overnight it's been brewing
for some time
the government of jersey keen to listen
with officials travelling to meet those
on the boats halfway
which led to what they say were
constructive talks
there are some growing pains which means
that
fishermen on both sides had perfectly
legitimate uh
grievances that we have been trying to
sort out we've been living near france
forever
um they're our neighbors we actually
hope to to develop
relationship our relationship with
france
but jersey's bidding with the eu is done
by westminster
the prime minister and channel island
officials meeting too
with clear confidence in calming the
fallout
a dramatic 24 hours for an island torn
between their neighbours
and who are determined not to be the
collateral damage of brexit
ashley haranak sky news in jersey